the jurogan experience what's the
biggest fish you've ever speared
uh a mile and it was about 400 pounds
holy [ __ ]
was it attached to a rope yeah it was
like so you're holding on to it like an
elastic um the spear is attached to a
bungee which is attached to a buoy so
the buoy when the fish takes off the
buoy takes off so you knew you were
going for marlin at the time no not at
all
wow i was going for tuna actually 400
pounds it was uh i was very scared that
he would spare me back which you know
would have been kind of fair enough
sorta yeah
[Laughter]
damn is that possible would he attack
you
that's him holy [ __ ] i was just guessing
i don't know that that's it officially
yeah i think you would know holy that's
the black marlin then i got it i think
it's huge
what did that taste like i've never had
marlin it's pretty good it's kind of
similar to sport fish yeah it's awesome
meat
wow look at the size of that [ __ ]
because most of the time they don't eat
them
why is that
um they can have high level of mercury
so you just like just don't eat old
thing i guess okay but it's it's yeah
it's amazing tasting
i gave away
um
a big part of it in mexico where i was
and i took back home about 50 pounds
with me
do you smoke it like how do you cook it
i only kept just
not too too much i probably kept like 10
pounds of it not even
so you brought 50 pounds home so you
just give away the other 40. yeah i
actually put on my instagram that i was
uh giving away marlin at the grocery
store corner of that food and that
street and i just came for it
and people just showed up really
i like meeting people
wow that's really nice that's that's
very cool of you
wow it was fun nobody killed me yet so
let's see jesus don't put that out there
so when you
shot this marlin how long before
you could actually get it in the boat
like how much time does it take after
you shoot a marlin it took me about two
hours so the fish basically just like
took off and
it was
as soon as i shot it so basically i
jumped like i was in the water and i
started smiling like coming from the
deep
and of course when i tried going to
where is it it was swimming away so i i
kind of just like turned around and
looking from the corner of my eye and he
just turned away because i was like
what's that thing not even looking at me
and he he turned around and gave me like
a complete like
shot so how far away
pretty close
probably from
me jamie so i said that's really i don't
know how's that in 15 feet of whatever
you guys are using
in america the free home of the brave
it's called feet not meters
four meters
and um so i was like okay my gun was
pretty small so i thought
i could either shoot in the gills but
then i would risk to just not go all the
way through it and you really want the
spear to go all the way through it
so i showed it mid-body
and the spear went through it and i went
back to the surface grab onto the buoy
one buoy is not a lot for fish that's
that big and you just hung on to the
buoy for a ride i like
bear hugged depuy and i was yelling at a
boat bring me that bird you have a big
fish on
wow and the boat comes like super
quickly
and basically it was another guy in the
water so like i have to take like take
the other people out of the water making
sure everything is clear meanwhile am i
hanging on to the buoy
the boat comes in throws me into the
buoy i'm clipping the fish is like
swimming like it's my snorkel it's like
with the wind in the water that thing is
going and then i had a second buoyant
like okay this is more pressure so now
the fish is dragging an elastic rope
that's like you know creating pressure
two breweries and me wow so i'm kind of
waiting for it to slow down and to tie
it up
when i feel there's no pressure anymore
so there's like a clip and then the
bungee cord i like i put it up i put it
up and then when the fish come close
enough so i had a second smaller gun to
give it like like a last shot basically
and
the first seven to eight times the fish
that slightly was seeing me was going
back down and i'm like
for [ __ ] sakes
like jesus
and then i keep pulling the fish up
keeps it i'm like i'm not feeling good
like i'm like i'm feeling so bad i puked
after it as that but you're so much
adrenaline and you're like using all
your energy and the last time he was
just like he had no energy left so i
managed to give a second shot then i
brained it and then oh in the brain
so went back to the surface where do you
shoot and to get the brain so most of
the times basically right behind the eye
so kind of behind the top of the head
and the eye that's kind of where the
fish brain is
so i played it
when your brain didn't just stiffen up
they just stop they kind of like you
like shake it a little bit and um
i just stopped moving then you just
bleed it
and
put it back in the boat wow i didn't
talk the entire way
really i was just like with my mat open
and people were talking i was like i was
like i can't right now i don't even know
what just happened
that's so big
400 pounds is so big to shoot with a
spear gun so we get we got to the duck
and there's like a bunch of like
mexicans gathering it's like oh nice
you're like who got that and they
pointed like the girl in the background
i'm like me
that's hilarious
do you like that that you
are like this like
it's it's thin girl that's killing these
giant look at the size of that thing
my god
that is huge that was a nice fish it's
so wide
wow that is cool
is that the spear that's laying on top
of it yeah that's the spirit wow
that's massive it was so great i was i
was i was sorry shotgun i could barely
barely speak how long is it
how long is the fish yeah
don't give me meters either good
question
it looks like it's like nine or ten feet
long is that right uh yeah it's a
probably like a good like something like
that yeah wow that's awesome
well you thinking at any point in time
like oh my god i bit off more than i can
chew
yeah definitely
after i showed it i was like oh [ __ ]
what am i doing just letting
that i'm gonna get dragged to the bottom
of the ocean hanging on this buoy it's
like this may be my last day but wow it
will be a fun one
have you shot anything big other than
that like is that the by far the biggest
thing you've ever shot yeah that's by
far the biggest one i ever shot